our dream for this show is to be a
community that is forever growing and
that's why we teamed up with lovey j
jones
um lovie aj jones a best-selling uh new
york times author a podcast host
and the co-creator of the online
phenomenon share
the mic campaign which continues here on
this show to give
amazing black women a platform so their
voices can be heard
and we can ignite change hi lovey
hi drew lovey you look so beautiful
thank you thank you had to show up for
you oh my god your hair color and your
lip color
and just and it's like perfect with your
book in the back um
which i love the cover of um so
let's talk about kelly today who we're
going to share
the mic with um i'm honored to be doing
this with you as
always um tell us about kelly
kelly is a unicorn kelly's an adventurer
a licensed pilot
an advanced open scuba diver and the
first black woman to host a show for the
uh travel channel so it's called
mysterious islands she is just
wildly fascinating um i would like to
bring her
out now please welcome the amazing kelly
edwards
oh kelly you're in the maldives right
now right at night
yes i'm at the molding tonight i'm at so
maybe johnny living my best life city
here with you this is all like a dream
come true right now
and i'm talking with you and my amazing
friend lovey so thank you so much for
having me tonight
lovey knows all the coolest people and
it's so exciting for us to get to
co-pilot yes pun intended with her
in this most important endeavor of share
the mic now
kelly why did you so you became a pilot
yes why did you want to get your pilot's
license
well when i was pursuing the amazing
career wanting to be an adventure travel
journalist i was seeing all these bad
ass hoes going to these really far from
faces
however they were getting on a plane to
go there but they were not flying
themselves so i said
ah-ha that's how i'm gonna up this
adventure travel journalist game
i'm gonna become a pilot and fly myself
to my own destinations i'm not going to
wait on anyone to take me where i need
to go
no that's what i do you have a podcast
that's uh with travel and leisure
i have a question what should we be
thinking about
as far as travel right now and where
it's going in the future
well i think travel will come back
really really strong um
travel is a beautiful thing but there's
also over tourism right
and while that may be great for capital
gains it's terrible
for sustainability and preserving the
culture and the history
truly of a destination in a place um
this slowdown has
helped a lot of places be able to recoup
but it's also an opportunity for the
world to be cohesively
become a better place with each other to
treat your fellow mankind better
race gender identity and i think this is
the time now
to have this moment through the pandemic
to really assess the world and how
it is you have to be more aware of your
fellow mankind and i think that's a
beautiful thing
i think when i was doing my research on
you i came up with this saying because
you were talking about
travel and its new era and it was like
instead of fry
fly the friendly skies it's like fly the
respectful skies
and the way that you've been showing
you know and will continue to do so in
your podcast
how we can evolve in our journeys which
are so important and we can never lose
sight of them
but our travels will become different
and even better now
thank you i think it's very important
oh thank you kelly so much i'm so sorry
i thank you
so much for being on our show also kelly
is going to be taking over
my personal instagram page and i'm going
to share it with her so to find out more
about kelly
head to my instagram and lovey thank you
again for always doing this with us i
can't wait
to do more kelly everything i can hand
over to you
please i'm honored to be doing this with
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you